[موسيقى]
عندما
تبدأ العمل في أرض قاحلة ، فإن أول
شيء تتخيله هو
الفراغ
ولكنك ستندهش من التنوع
المخفي ،
اسمي إيريكا كويلار سوتو ، أنا
أصلاً من بوليفيا ، لكني هنا في
عمان أعمل أستاذاً لتدريس
الصحراء  البيولوجيا
والتنوع البيولوجي
جنبًا إلى جنب مع غابات المانغروف ، لدينا
أنواع مثل هذه
وهم يعتمدون على تكوين غابات المانغروف ،
فأنا هنا في جامعة السلطان كابوز
ولدي طلاب من
أجزاء مختلفة من البلاد وهذا بالنسبة
لي أمر استراتيجي للغاية لأنه
عندما ينتهون  الجامعة
هم علماء أحياء جدد وسيعودون
إلى مناطقهم
في البلد
[موسيقى]
نحن نطور تعاونًا مثيرًا للاهتمام للغاية
مع متحف التاريخ الطبيعي
في التميمة
نحن نطور مشاريع مع
الطلاب من أجل المساهمة في
عينات من أجل  المتحف الذي يمثل
تنوع البلد ،
انظر إلى هذا
هنا
حيث قد ترى أن الأجيال الشابة
مهتمة جدًا به  التكنولوجيا
لذلك من الصعب بالنسبة لي أن أجذبهم
فقط لرؤية الطبيعة بطريقة مختلفة ،
ما هو الاختلاف الذي نريده فقط
أن نأخذ مثالًا على هذا حسنًا ، نريد أن
نرى ما إذا كانت الرواسب أو الزيت ، حسنًا ،
فهم أساسًا من سكان الصحراء ليكونوا
داخل الغابة منعش للغاية ، إنه
مختلف تمامًا عما اعتادوا رؤيته
هل كنت في مكان آخر مثل هذا
قبل أن تكون في حالة حب عندما تذهب داخل
المانجو ، فأنا اصطحب الطلاب إلى
بيئات مختلفة وأشجار المانغروف هي
شيء يجذبهم حقًا
يعد الحفاظ على [موسيقى]
في الشرق الأوسط
أمرًا مهمًا لأنه
في أي مكان في العالم نواجه
وقتًا عصيبًا للغاية
من حيث
صحة كوكبنا ،
آمل ولكن في نفس الوقت
أريدهم أن يكونوا واقعيين أريدهم أن
يفهموا  أننا بحاجة إلى الاستثمار في
اكتساب المعرفة والتقدم في
العلوم ،
أعتقد
أن هذه المنطقة
تستحق الاهتمام
فهي منطقة غنية جدًا ولا ينبغي
تجاهلها ولا ينبغي لنا تجاهل
أي منطقة قاحلة  س